fusillade meurtrière ce matin à kazan en
russie bilan provisoire au moins neuf
morts confirmés et une trentaine de
blessés
un adolescent de dix neuf mois de 19 ans
a été interpellé une vingtaine
d'ambulances ont été dépêchés sur place
les élèves ont été évacués
le kremlin exprime ses condoléances aux
familles des victimes et déclare vouloir
revoir ses règles en matière de
détention d'armes à feu
la correspondance en russie signé
anthony claireaux antoine de quelles
informations disposif disposez-vous à
cette heure ci
et là je me trouve juste devant la
représentation de la république du
tatarstan
ici à mon secours où de nombreuses
personnes viennent rendre hommage aux
victimes en déposant un bouquet de
fleurs une bougie une peluche et
d'ailleurs on peut remarquer que
beaucoup parmi ces parmi ces gens qui
viennent rendre hommage
on remarque qu'il ya beaucoup
d'adolescents de gens du même âge des
victimes de cette horrible tragédie
le représentant le représentant du
tatarstan ici à moscou est venue il ya
tout juste quelques minutes répondre aux
questions de la presse il a d'ailleurs
fait savoir qu'ils n'avaient pas de mots
pour qualifier cette tragédie alors pour
rappel il ya bien eu au moins neuf morts
c'est le bilan le bilan à l'heure
actuelle et parmi eux au moins sept
enfants âgés de 14 15 ans ainsi que leur
professeur est également 16 blessés
parmi les élèves et l'équipe de l'école
alors au départ les autorités pensaient
qu'il y avait deux assaillants qui
avaient pris pour cible cette école mais
au final il y aurait au final qu'un seul
attaquant qui a d'ailleurs été
interpellé par les forces de police se
propose d'écouter le commentaire du
président de la république du tatarstan
qui dresse le profil du principal
suspect terry liston
le terroriste de 19 ans a été arrêté il
est propriétaire d'une arme enregistrée
officiellement à hélium d'autres
potentiels complices n'ont pas encore
été identifiés l'enquêté en cours
toutes les forces sont déployés mais je
collais toute l'assistance nécessaire
sera apporté à l'école et aux familles
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui est une
énorme tragédie pour l'ensemble de notre
république et pour notre pays
nous sommes vraiment infligée alors
sitôt la police arrivée sur les lieux du
drame et bien le quartier d'école a été
entièrement bouclé l'école en elle même
a été complètement évacué et les autres
établissements scolaires de la ville de
kazan ont été placées sous surveillance
le porte parole du kremlin a fait savoir
que vladimir poutine présente est d'ores
et déjà ses condoléances aux familles
aux proches des victimes
il a également fait savoir que le
président russe tenez à revoir la
législation concernant le port d'armes
écoutez dmitri peskov le président a
chargé le gouvernement d'apporter son
aide d'assurer la prestation de soins
médicaux ainsi qu'un soutien
psychologique aux enfants touchés et
blessés et de fournir une assistance
nécessaire aux familles des victimes
victor zolotow le directeur de la garde
nationale de russie a été chargée de la
mission spéciale de rédiger d'urgence un
nouveau règlement sur les types d'armes
qui peuvent être vendus au civil est
détenu par la population en prenant en
compte le type d'armes légères utilisées
par la cia le président transmet ses
profondes condoléances aux familles des
enfants tuées par le tireur et adresse
ses voeux de prompt rétablissement aux
écoliers blessés
alors l'enquète ne fait que commencer
les forces de l'ordre recherchent en
particulier la présence d'éventuels
complices le président de la république
du tatarstan a pour sa part fait savoir
que la journée de demain la journée du
12 mai serait jours de deuil à travers
toute la république du tatarstan
merci antoine claireaux depuis moscou en
russie